اذا سجلت الساعات الماضيه احداثا عسكريه
لافته في تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
خصوصا على الجبهه البحريه فقد ناجت او
نجحت المسيرات البحريه الاوكرانيه في
استهداف قطع الاسطول الروسي في عمق قواعده
بالبحر الاسود وتعرضت ناقله نفط روسيه
لهجوم بزورق اوكراني مسير قرب مضيق كريتش
وجسري شبه جزيره القرن ويمكن للمسيرات
البحريه الاوكرانيه الصنع والمسلحه ب 300
كيلو غرام من المتفجرات اصابه هدف على بعد
500 ميل
وقال المتحدث باسم الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه
اندريوس ان استهداف السفن العسكريه
الروسيه نتيجه طبيعيه لتداعيات العدوان
الروسي على اوكرانيا وفق تعبيره واضاف
يصوب ان الاسطول الروسي لم يعد محصنا امام
هجمات بوسائل صغيره لكنها حديثه
مؤخرا عمليه بمسيارات مجهوله واستهدفت سفن
الدعم العسكريه واحدى سفن الانزالي في
الاسطول الروسي هذه نتيجه طبيعيه وواضحه
لتداعيات العدوان الروسي واحتلال اراضينا
الاسطولوسيون لم يعد محصن امام وسائل
صغيره محدثه ولا يمكن للمحتلين الشعور
بالامان في كل المناطق سيكون من الصعب على
الروسي في المستقبل القريب لاستعاده سفينه
الانزال جارنياك
ومازن ابراهيم هناك اذا نتابع معك اخر
التصريحات البيانات ايضا الصادره من
الجانب الاوكران
في الواقع السفيان يمكن الجزم والقول ان
طالما ان اتفاقيه تصدير الحبوب لم تفعل او
لم يتم ايجاد حل جديد لها بما يتيح
لاوكرانيا اعاده تصدير حبوبها فان ميدان
المواجهه سيظل مفتوحا في البحر الاسود
والمنازله واستهداف السفن الحربيه سيكون
مفتوحا خلال كل الفتره المقبله هذا الامر
عززته قبل قليل قبل نحو ساعتين كان هنالك
بيان من القوات البحريه الاوكرانيه رفع من
سقف المواجهه هو ادرج سته موانئ روسيه
نتحدث عن موانئ روسيه على الساحل الروسي
المشاطئ لشبه جزيره القرم اعتبر بان هذه
الموانئ بالاضافه الى المسطحات المائيه
المحيطه بها هي مناطق وصفها بانها مناطق
عمل حربي وعدائي بمعنى ان سقف المواجهه
ترفعه اليوم اوكرانيا
بشكل واضح ورسمي ولاول مره حديث واضح جازم
بان هذه المرافق الروسيه اصبحت اهدافا هو
يتحدث عن سته مرافق سته مرافق هذه المرافق
جزء منها خمسه منها على طول الساحل
المقابل لشبه جزيره القرم من ناحيه البحر
الاسود
ومرفا سادس من ناحيه بحر ازوف عمليا هذا
الكلام سيفتح باب المواجهه على مصراعيه
وبعدما كانت التسريبات تاتي من خلال وسائل
الاعلام وبعض المسؤولين الامنيين على
مستوى الاستهدافات للعمق الروسي اليوم بات
واضحا من خلال بيان رسمي للجيش الاوكراني
يعتبر بان هذه المنطقه هي مناطق عمليات
عسكريه وبالعوده الى التصريحات التي صدرت
اليوم وتحديدا من رئيس جهاز امن الدوله هو
اعتبر بان كل هذه العمليه العمليات التي
ينفذها الجهاز والتي تنافذها القوات
الاوكرانيه في البحر الاسود من خلال
استهداف السفن اعتبر انها مبرره وفق
القانون الدولي وفق المواثيق الدوليه على
اعتبار اولا بان هذه المناطق هي مناطق
محتله وثانيا ان من يتم استهدافه هي سفن
اما كانت اما عسكريه او سفن لتزويد القوات
الروسيه سواء بالعتاد او حتى بالنفط وغيره
من المواد والمحروقات وبالتالي ضمن هذه
المعادله باتت تتحرك القوات الاوكرانيه من
خلال استخدام المسيرات المائيه والتي باتت
اقل كلفه ماديه واقل كلفه بشريه ولكنها
تؤدي الى اضرار كبيره على مستوى حركه
الشحن الروسيه من الموانئ الروسيه ضمن
البحر الاسود وبالتالي هذا هو شعار
المرحله التي رفعته القياده الاوكرانيه
على مستوى المواجهه في البحر وتحديدا في
البحر الاسود وبالتالي نحن مقبلون خلال
المرحله المقبله والايام المقبله على رفع
لمستوى المواجهه على مستوى الميداني يمكن
الحديث عن تصريح اللافته لنائبه وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني اليوم عندما قالت بانه
لاول مره تمكنت القوات الاوكرانيه من خرق
خط الدفاع الاول جنوب البلاد في الجبهه
الجنوبيه وتقدمت الى خط الدفاع الاوسط
القوات الروسيه هي بطبيعه الحال لم تحدد
اين هذه الامكنه ولكن يجب الحديث عن خرسون